the magnus effect with magnus carlsen
and magnus barstod
welcome to the first episode of the
minus effect i am minus carlson and i am
magnus barstad we
we decided to go with uh
with the exact same name this time right
yes yeah it's not confusing at all when
you
when you
handshake with someone it's like my name
is magnus yeah my name is magnus ii um
but it's easier that way isn't it yeah
it's okay yeah it's okay uh our first uh
episode ever and today we are going to
be talking about our trip to vegas
uh
we are gonna do the first bet ever for
this pod like this is a sports and
wedding podcast so we are going to do
some bets
uh
magnus he's gonna the other magnus he's
gonna talk a little bit about
uh the upcoming world chess championship
and
at the end we are gonna have the first
of many wagers
it's um
we'll introduce that when we get to it
right yeah yeah okay
uh
so let's just start off with part one
welcome to the pod
the magnus effect is brought to you by
unibet by players four players
so i got here from madrid where
i did a few sponsor events for puma
mastercard some for
just24 as well
um
and
the plan was to stay here for one day
and then start playing the main event
what happened is
the morning after i arrived a lot of
people i knew they started messaging me
saying that i should play the main event
that day instead of the next
uh because there
it would probably be ten handed the next
day and then you know it would be very
very crowded at the table and as
uh they said
it would be pretty much like flying
coach and i was thinking yeah i'm not
too keen on
keen on doing that
um
after what had been a pretty long travel
uh so i decided to play um
to play the the very same day
uh i have to say overall
uh
i'm not very proud of my performance in
the
in the main event
um usually when you play a tournament i
mean i wouldn't know but
you can think of like a few
spots
whereas whereas like oh yeah i made a
pretty good decision there
or yeah this could have gone either way
but i thought it through i'm happy with
the line i took and so on
i cannot think of a single time that
happened
it was just
it was just a train wreck
was it worth it no it was i mean it was
okay uh
the trip i will talk about the trip
later but
i i mean i i feel kind of um it's a kind
of a bummer to
to play the main event and not to do
more like
a lot of people bust on day one do you
rather do it the way one of my
um one of my buddies did um
when he uh
um
he had a very nice stack over 100k and
he just
punted it all off on the first day
bluffing three streets with queen high
they got called with ace high
that was just that that was that was
brilliant
um
so i'll tell you that uh i had
uh
i had a couple of drinks later that
night with that guy um
and another one of his his friends who
had actually survived day one
uh but very with a very short stack and
we we went to this horrible
uh horrible place where they had like
these
all these different
sour beers and
um
basically
um
the two of us we just wanted to
chug down a couple of beers before
um
before going to sleep this other guy he
had been here for like a month
um and he had had a small stack uh he
wasn't gonna play the next day but the
day after was like oh but he
he actually had a
i think he had a master's or a bachelor
either one of them uh
in in brewing so he he just wanted to
to show um show us some really uh
nice beers that we could we could try uh
anyway
so we said yeah yeah sure uh let's let's
taste this beer
uh
yeah spoiler alert we chug chugged it
down anyway it was horrible um
anyway um
this guy uh for all
the
the mocking
we uh put on him for his sour beers
which were
horrible that nobody should drink that
sounds so bad yeah it was it was i mean
i understand like if you've studied it
and everything but why is that yet uh i
know but anyway he was um
he was definitely a very very uh nice
friendly friendly guy we
uh we all talked for a little bit then
yeah we went home
and the guy with a short stack he had a
pretty nice day two and three and four
and five and six and seven and eight and
nine however
many days it lasted and he won the main
event
[Laughter]
so
i guess
overall uh his strategy worked pretty
pretty well and uh to be fair i watched
a bit he played uh amazing and he was a
massively uh deserved winner so yeah he
played he actually played amazing yeah i
did play amazing so
that was that was the main event story
uh and um what can i say i did horribly
but at least i did get
to mock the main event
winner which i think was deserved
you got them walking for for uh sour
bears i don't know i'll guess i i guess
we'll take it um
but what's
the the bluff you had in the main event
just very shortly was that the was that
the worst bluff you've had in vegas
playing
poker no that's not that's not even
close to the worst bluff
so i'll tell you i played
um i played cash another day at the
bellagio um the fairly high stakes game
and it went went well i had a i had a
solid win there um then there was this
um
influencer streamer game which
kind of went haywire in many many ways
production wise a couple of people
didn't didn't show up which was
uh unfortunate but that's something some
things that
can happen
economically for me it went okay i mean
i just decided that
i was going to play really really simple
poker and
if everyone folded every time you did
anything though yeah but that
that was okay like i didn't have
any major
spots where i met wanted to create great
actions so that that was that was okay
like i people also folded when i didn't
want to get action so
but everyone wants to hear about the
worst bluff ever yeah
uh
um
but yeah so there was one other session
where i just decided uh to play some
uh what was it like it's 10 20. 10 20.
at at the whole
the hotel we're staying
this started out fine
i won a nice spot early on when i when i
caught a
caught a bluff on on the river
then nothing much happened until i
decided to
um i mean there was a straddle there so
we were playing 10 20 40. uh one guy
from then you're basically pot committed
right yeah obviously
uh
yeah so
what happened was that a couple of guys
limped
the small blind made it 220. um
i decided to get a little bit frisky
from the
from the straddle uh and i made it 550
all the guys folded
um the guy
from the small blind who was clearly
like a good player
which i could see from the from the
other
other hands he'd played i just decided i
wanted to try and i'll play it i had i
had four three of hearts by the way
and uh
yeah so he he called
uh
the flop came 10-8-7 a couple of clubs
um
and um he uh uh well i decided to lead
out for 300.
he made it 720
and at this point i thought ah
okay i kind of want to leave
i'm sick of playing i've been playing
for like one and a half hours at that
point i can leave now
i'll have like small loss no worries
or i can just rip it
so i ripped it for
like 1900 more
he didn't even think for one second
before calling
the poor uh the turn was it was a jet
no it was a nine
river was like
some big card i don't remember like a
king or something anyway i mean i
i was not even close to not playing the
board
um so i just mocked my card and
left with um you basically have the
worst hand you can have i had the
oh no no there was a deuce no obviously
the river was was a deuce so i had the
absolute anti-nuts
[Laughter]
which is also something and that's the
last hand you played right yeah that was
the last one i mean i figured the guy
probably had jacks or something i didn't
even care i was never going to play with
any of those guys ever again
so yeah uh
no the first the first bluff i talked
about i think it was reasonable maybe i
should have sized up but this one i
didn't even believe in i just wanted to
i just wanted to punt off
yeah
so uh
yeah some some bad play some good play i
guess we'll summarize that and uh
you should you shouldn't uh
uh you should you should you shouldn't
just shrug off the worst bluff of all
time it's it's
it's something to
to remember definitely
so we have been now in las vegas for
two weeks almost just about two weeks
um
i can say that two weeks in vegas might
just be
a tad on the heavy side
yeah
i would say the the first week was uh
was great um
the poor group was obviously up and down
but we had
a lot of
fun things we had the summer league as
well which is summer league in general
yeah summer league is great summer
league is great
uh for me uh uh i mean two weeks was
probably too much to begin with uh but
especially since i
started to feel a bit sick on on sunday
um
yeah last week and then
i mean the last week i haven't been able
to
to do much uh at all i went to summer
league one day when we were invited by
by daryl mori and the sixers just very
nice uh but i wasn't feeling great and i
had to leave at half time and i
even got even worse
on that note i have to tell you the
story that i refuse to tell you okay
nice i've been i've been waiting
so uh
uh the nba summer league is something
that it's uh held in vegas every summer
it's the
prospects and the draft picks and people
trying to get into the nba it's just
loads of games um at the thomas and mac
center and it's
it's just
a lot of fun it's
it's highly recommended highly
recommended
if you're a massive basketball nerd uh
we'll also get
get into that later we are both massive
basketball nerds like massive not
american massive massive basketball
nerds uh
but at that after half time at the
philly philly heat game when we were
invited by our you were invited by daryl
mori uh magnus decided to go home
because he was feeling properly under
the weather and i decided to stay for
the second half so when magnus leave
leaves as soon as half time buzzer goes
you know we stand up on the floor and we
just stand chatting right so it's me
daryl moria and coach jaeger and and the
other guy who i actually unfortunately
can't remember the name of the chess
player
oh uh
yeah okay but he was it was great to
talk to though so the the sorry about
not remembering names absolute delight
anyway
overcomes jj redick
nba player jj redick now turned
announcer he is calling the game so he's
calling the game for espn oh he missed
took you for me didn't he
so
so jj ready comes over no
and he just shakes daryl's hand and goes
all right darryl great to see you
and then he shakes my hand and he goes
jj and i go magnus as i do my name is
magnus
and he goes yeah great i'm a huge fan of
you
so i'm like
what
are jj redick is a huge fan of me
and he just looks at me like that yeah i
follow all your stuff
you're a great champion and at that
point i'm realizing oh jesus he's
talking about the other magnets he is
not
aware that other magnus has gone
uh
i'm i'm a massive nba fan and i really
like jj redick as a player and as an
announcer so i'm not at my
peak game right here
i obviously should have gone with the
joke
i obviously should have gone with a joke
but it would have got so much better
than even i could could have imagined so
i
say at that point that i'm not you and
i'm a different guy and he's very polite
and we talk a little bit about sports
betting blah blah blah
and
uh he walks off again we sit down
and daryl says ah you should you
shouldn't have said that was you
why
because
jj once wanted to invite magnus on
espn to commentate the game with him in
the second half
that could have been you pretending to
be you could have been the magnus carl
carlton symposium
for the whole second half and i'm like
no
no
practical like absolute golden practical
joke went out the window i that's why i
said i'm i'm it's a good story but i'm
mainly just killing myself
wow
i mean
a little bit of quick thinking
in that spot like perform under pressure
yeah
i know as i said i'm taking i'm taking
just i don't think anyone could be a
harsher uh a harsher
archer critic than i am of myself in in
a spot like that i'm absolutely killing
myself over that
ah that would have been so great
you know how it goes on the espn then he
goes
magnus carlsen world chess champion
and it's my bald fat ass
they're
talking about kenny left and junior
uh that was uh that was uh yeah
uh it could have been great
anyway
uh another thing about because we we
briefly we briefly went on to on to the
americans and
as uh maybe
most listeners know we are both
norwegian or at least you're in the
region now i'm in the region as well
uh and norwegians were kind of closed
off people right
yeah yeah we don't walk up to strangers
and just talk to them
nope nope americans do though
yeah they do they really do they really
really do and if they are here you have
a different uh
like a different dialect or speak a
different language they're all over it
like where you're from uh
so i've i've had a
i've actually had more encounters with
random people the last two weeks and
i've had probably the last two years at
least that's undercoved last ten years
probably because they just come up and
start talking to you which i find a bit
annoying but it's okay
uh
our like our standard answer has been
why are you here we're here to watch the
summer league and play some poker right
yeah yeah
uh
so i just have to tell uh to tell people
about two of the americans that came up
to me and started talking and the uh and
and uh i said like oh yeah we're we're
here to watch the summer league we've
been every day we we love basketball
uh
so there was this one guy who went
yeah basketball that's my favorite sport
i'm like okay yeah okay so you like
basketball cool we can actually have a
conversation then
and i was like okay so
you know have you been to summer league
no is that in vegas
yes
i live in vegas i didn't know i was like
what
there are posters all over yeah i don't
i don't leave her all year but
okay you haven't noticed the summer
league being here every year that's okay
okay uh so i i i i understand quickly
that this this might not be
you know he might not be that into
basketball as as he as he stated from
the start but i give it another pops out
i'm like so who's your favorite team oh
i'm a huge miami heat fan
he's from miami he lives part-time in
miami part-time in
in in vegas huge miami fan been to loads
of games grew up massive fan played
basketball all his life
and then he like he just tells this like
he he tells it with such confidence that
he's like the biggest basketball fan and
he loves the heat
and then he asks me the following
question
is wayne wade still playing
how can you do that
i don't know maybe he used to be
yeah it's it's hard that's bad yeah but
it's not as bad as the next one no the
next one is worse the next one is a lot
worse
so when you played the celebrity poker
game um
a girl came up to me and you know just
hello i started talking in the same
thing summer league oh i love basketball
it's my favorite sport of all time i'm
such a basketball fan it's my go-to
sport blah blah blah
all the things like like she sounds like
she's a hundred times bigger fan of the
nba than both of us combine right i love
basketball actually i started going to
san antonio games in 2016. like i loved
the spurs when i lived there i went to
loads of games
so i just went for a safe one i was like
alright so you got to watch the great
team duncan at the end then
you've been to loads of san antonio
games and you don't know who team duncan
is
no but i moved to denver quite shortly
after and i just went to loads of
nuggets nuggets games i love
going to nuggets games i've been like i
had had like a season ticket with my
friend and we went all the time
i was like okay so you went all the time
then then you had to
have seen the great the great nikola
jokic the two-time mvp of the league
who
then she went like i'm not like you i'm
not like a nerd nerd i don't know the
player's names
ah
did did she understand when you
described like the really tall skilled
one
i said you have to have noticed the
seven foot one
weird-looking white dude that's just
killing everyone every game
not really
wow
to be fair didn't duncan retire in 2016.
yeah then she probably caught the tail
end of him that's what i said oh okay
maybe if she like moved early 2016 then
okay she she might have gotten that uh
she she might have gotten she might have
gotten away on the technicality there
yeah
but but the joker that's a big fat yeah
but still unfortunately if you go to
loads of spurs games like i would
i would almost bank on you knowing who
he is but like the the
go being a seasoned ticket holder at
nuggets games and don't know who jokic
is that is just beyond anything no but i
i went to uh just to put it in a
norwegian context i went to evolving a
game recently yeah apparently the kids
don't know who morton buddy is
yeah so
did he retired 15 years ago no
at least then six years ago maybe no
come on
someone needs to find the fact there so
we're not going to check it but
he has to be close to 50 like 47 8. yeah
but he played pretty okay no we have to
maybe like eight years we could google
this right now but we're not gonna do
that so
uh but yeah i think that's typically
american like oh i'm such a big fan
there's also people who are such big
chess fans and then they know
very little which is for example
which is okay
sorry jj
well we actually really like jj uh i i'm
not holding this against him because
i think that's just the way they are
like it's so overstated it's crazy
uh
yeah we're not here to kill americans
though uh any more than uh anymore than
this we've we've enjoyed our stages i'm
so happy that i didn't stay after
halftime yeah
i would have been of course even happier
if you had uh gone through with the with
the whole thing yeah at some point it
must have um
they must have caught it but yeah who
knows like i i saw this documentary it
could have gone on i i think i could
have sat through it you know i saw this
documentary the i talked about the
documentary i saw on espn the other day
the great imposter yeah of the late 70s
and star of 80s like you could have been
the new one this could have kick-started
your career yeah but you told me about
that documentary the day after this
happened
it's so bad
i've if i'd had that inspiration i would
have definitely gone for it uh we we
have to do one more thing before we wrap
the wig as part of this off uh uh up
it's the
okay so we have stayed at the win right
yeah just do a short review on the win
so
good things bad things
i mean a lot of good things yeah it's
feels cleaner a bit newer a bit nicer
quite spacious spacious
rooms are nice yeah uh
the the club was this
okay yeah shaq was there which was
pretty pretty great
um
few things that are not
that
great um so about five nba teams uh
or the summer league teams uh are are at
the hotel right yeah i mean no more i
think because there were a few both at
encore and at when yeah and the showers
are at like five foot eleven yeah which
is really nice
it's annoying for us you're you're five
eleven or six foot you're six foot yeah
you're six foot i'm six foot one like
it's it's annoying but how about the
seven foot guys how are they
and it's not like they're hung up under
the roof you've got a full meter on top
of them that you you could uh
it's it's crazy it's like it must be
really annoying for them to get in the
shower at the five-star hotel anyway
keep going
oh yeah i was gonna i was gonna say um
just yesterday um
i saw
a couple of like six foot ten uh seven
foot guys i think one of them was mark
williams didn't recognize the other one
yeah um
anyway uh there were some american
tourists like taking pictures with with
them they had no idea who they were they
were like
just like oh you're basketball players
you're so you're so tall like how do you
how do you not like how do you not
bearing your head into the wall every
time
like oh they probably never heard that
before that's nice well they probably
never heard that they're at all before
since they're seven foot um
anyway yeah so things that weren't
that great well first of all
um
food there is the food the quality of
the food is good but there is no where
to get food yeah that's that's the main
problem it's really really hard to get
food uh
uh like the room service takes forever
yeah it's impossible to get food under
an hour like in under an hour it's
impossible
and everywhere else it's just overbooked
long
long lines i mean i mean i was
walking around
the valleys yeah um
[Music]
or ballis maybe it's just called um
in in one of the breaks of the
the world series i was shocked to see
there were so many restaurants yeah i
was thinking like they can't possibly
all be profitable but like
my friend you just said
no i mean this is america as soon as
something is losing money they just just
shut it down
everything's profitable and when i was
looking in the restaurants yeah every
one of them was full like
and there were restaurants on every
corner
it was just shocking and
massive hotels five restaurants yeah six
maybe
yeah it's crazy and they were constantly
all full
as as you said quality excellent
but
that was availability of breakfast
yeah like crazy bad
but there is one thing
uh one last thing we need to close off
this
this vegas part with
and it's it's
it's the lost cards
the hotel keys oh yeah okay uh
so
i'm a chess player
um
chess players
lose stuff
or a lot of chess players lose stuff
i do
like every time
that i'm staying at a hotel i'm gonna
lose
either lose a key or just leave it in
the room
at least once
uh
so it happened to me
once
this time
i stood in a little bit of a line at
the reception
and
it was okay uh there was a long line but
i thought it was like
and there was one line for people who
were checking in and one line for people
who just wanted other services it was
okay it took a little bit of time more
than i would have liked
yeah so it took a little bit of time
which is annoying mindly annoying but it
was okay um
there i mean i think
people are ahead of me in line they had
genuine
worries that they needed to take care of
so the next time
i lose my key i mean the same thing
happens again like immediately when i
leave the room i realized ugh i haven't
got my room key okay so i go down
i stand in the same line
um
there's one family father and two girls
in front of me
and they're taking forever
and i realize they're checking in
which is a little bit weird but but okay
um
anyway it takes forever i'm sure there
were legitimate worries but there was so
much back and forth
this takes 20 minutes
anyway i get to
um
i get to the front of the line
and i ask
the guy so i have sorry lost my key it's
possible to get a new one
and he says i have to get him back
of the line
which is
i think not ideal
first of all in the sense that there
should be like a separate line for
people
who are not checking in but
want services that take
from
10 seconds till
till a minute
but i mean he did notice that i was
standing in line for 20 minutes so
it would have been a nice courtesy to
tell me then
but then he said like i thought you were
with the others
and um i'm thinking and then saying oh
that's a bit weird
um first of all we don't look
particularly alike so it's unlikely that
we'd be a family
secondly i got there
a lot later
also i didn't talk to them at all
i don't have any luggage
it all seems a bit
yeah it all seems a bit weird
um so
i'm not particularly inclined at this
point to go back in line
um
and i asked him like i understand that i
i'll go back in line the next time but
seriously this is going to take 10
seconds
uh it's like no you have to go back in
line
and then another guy
who's gone
who's gotten in line behind me um he
gets to the
um
he goes to the counter and asks for some
toothpaste
and he's like about to
go like sure uh i can i can get to that
and at this point
that's just a joke though yeah at this
point i pull a massive dick move
and i i said look this guy clearly has
to get in the back of the line if i have
to get in the back of the line i
understand that his request is even
smaller than mine but still
he has to
he has to get back as well
um and so he's like yeah okay you have
to get back and then i just stood there
for a little bit and i think he was
feeling also a bit embarrassed by the
whole situation
well i i wasn't feeling embarrassed i
was just you're just pissed i was just
feeling a bit
you know i was
feeling pretty under the weather at that
point i was pissed uh i was dehydrated
uh and
i was just probably hungry because
there's no hungry as well i was i wasn't
going anywhere
at that point
so at some point he was yeah he just
felt embarrassed
and uh he just decided to
say [ __ ] it give me a key uh fortunately
on my idea so it it took literally took
10 seconds
anyway
the next day which was yesterday
um
i'll leave my room in the evening
wouldn't you know
you pat your you i can see you're
patting your pockets and you go
[ __ ] i did it again yeah like okay i got
yeah i'm always checking
passport
passport um
phone cash
key oh no no key
uh and i have like four buckets so it's
it's easy to check
so i go to the reception
good news
two people in line it's very easy so i
immediately get to the front yeah you
can go in the proper way
bad news
let's see it's the same guy
at the reception
um
anyway
i sort of sheepishly go up
[ __ ] wouldn't you know it lost my key
again i'm really really sorry
to be fair i said that i was really
sorry a couple of times
he didn't look me in the eye once gave
me my key
and that was the end of the story you
wanna know no it isn't the end of the
story and how you didn't discover this
even today baffles me beyond
anything
[Laughter]
so both times you were gonna get your
key you had your passport right yeah
yeah
you see those machines on the left
by checking you can just press missed
key put your passport in and get a new
key out from the machine
okay so to be fair
he could have said that to be fair he
yeah one he could have said that
and
the first time
the ones before me in line they
specifically asked why the machine did
not work
all the machines didn't work the first
time yeah but they did work the second
time and they did work today at checkout
which was a nice surprise yeah
i loved
took a little bit of of
of the sting out of it for me but when i
checked out on those machines today and
i saw they had lost car there i was
laughing so hard like it was
it was embarrassing how hard i laughed
at it
okay anyway doubles vegas yeah that was
vegas
ups and downs a little bit too long uh
wish i hadn't gotten sick probably will
affect me
nah it's okay
the magnus effect with magnus carlsen
and magnus barstead brought to you by
unibet
okay welcome back so we are going to get
into one of the segments that we're
going to try to have every time uh one
of the things that i bring to the table
in this pod is that i have been a
professional sports bettor now for about
10 years and
[Music]
together with unibets that we
were both
cooperating with
we are gonna try to give you some good
bets that you can
follow or not follow whatever you like
um
and we're gonna start it off with
with the season bet and it's uh our
fellow norwegian who's gone to
man city for uh
a major transfer huge star we're we're
proud of erling broad holland right
online which we would say yeah yeah
obviously yeah yeah we're proud of the
lad he's he's really good yeah
uh so he's gone to city a major
major move uh he's expected to
be the top goal scorer in the prem he's
leading the odds he's four four times so
if you hear this podcast in your english
or uh american or whatever we're gonna
we are gonna do the european style odds
they are by far the eastest odds to
calculate
uh so we're going to do the the
the numbers
you have to
if you have to get your calculator out
to to understand it be my guest
but anyway he's the he's the leading
favorite to be the top goal scorer in
the prem now at four times the money
before salah
any thoughts on that
i can see
uh i can see that um i think the two of
them are
clearly the two hottest candidates to be
[Music]
um to be the top scorer um
i think
son although he is
um probably the greatest finisher in
football apart from messi
had an unsustainably hot season
last year and it's probably going to
regress a bit the wild card is kane kane
is definitely the wild card yeah um
other candidates um
we can talk about nunes if you want
i
i said before that
i
believed he was going to be a best that
was before
he went to liverpool
which hasn't changed my mind
but
it's
made me a little bit less confident in
that particular take
um
because they usually don't miss on these
big transfers big big transfers
like
some i mean
generally they've hit most of the
transfers recently but especially the
big ones they haven't
really um really missed uh at all um my
thing was that
to me it seemed like he couldn't do too
much except
accept scoring and that he would be
a liability uh in
the link up play and that he was also
running unsustainably hot
in the one really really good season he
had
last year um but now
that
anyway i'm derailing the conversation
he's not going to be close to the top
scorer no i don't think he's going to be
the top scorer uh
because there's one important i mean if
he scores 17 goals that's very very good
yeah his line is 14 and a half
which i would say him scoring between 12
and 17 goals just sounds bang on yeah i
agree um
before he went to liverpool
i was
telling people that
if line is if he goes to let's say
arsenal i would bet on him scoring
uh i would bet the under on 12 and a
half
at liverpool obviously i wouldn't
but
yeah fourteen and a half
yeah it's probably back on unfortunately
but we're getting back to
too early right yeah uh so hold on
his line is and i've like as soon as he
signed you could see all the big
accounts on twitter and all the small
accounts for that matter people just
going crazy
he's gonna score 40 goals yes blah blah
and i think that i think he's so good
that he can score 40 goals for city like
no doubt i think he can score 45 even
but there's a couple of things like dude
that i like to check off when i do do
these bets
and okay so there is a massive hype on
him scoring a lot of goals which should
mean the line is a couple of ticks
higher than what it should be because
people want to bet the high line on him
right
then
secondly you have to look at how old is
he how sustainable is he and his fitness
and he just turned 22
a couple of weeks ago i think
uh
he has been quite injury prone
and that's been for playing for the
norwegian national team and for dortmund
and now he's gonna play in an even
tougher league and he's gonna play a lot
more games
like they they have a lot more games so
the question i don't think he's gonna
play a lot no i mean i have a hard time
seeing him play three games a week
basically ever that's that and that was
my whole point there because they have a
lot more games but is he gonna play a
lot more games
that is the question where i think where
most people miss the mark on stuff like
this
uh
he played
uh
20
uh no he he scored 22
and 27 in the two first seasons at
dortmund and he played two thousand and
two thousand four hundred minutes
i i would not be shocked if he doesn't
play a lot more than two thousand
minutes for city in the prem next year
and and as you've seen before like
has scored
20 plus goals on
2000 minutes before yeah
um don't quote me on that but i'm pretty
sure like he he's never been a high
minutes guy like he's always missed he's
always best games
this is gonna he's he really gonna score
25 goals
in his first season like he's a young
player he's a physical beast but they're
gonna be playing at all fronts very very
likely they're playing in both domestic
cups they're playing well into the
champions league he's going to be
playing for the national team and he's
going to be playing in the prem he's a
young player i think if he's ever going
to get to the say the 40 goal mark in
the prem or the 35 goal mark i think it
it's in
two or three years when he has when his
body is better worked in when he's done
growing done learning the league done
uh
like settling into the player he's gonna
be because physically and like uh
you know just being a top top top tier
professional doesn't come that easily
when you're 22 years old and i think he
for his potential it's crazy because i
don't think he's even touching the top
of his potential but that's my point
like i think he's a couple of years off
being the absolute model pro
no i i agree um
and i think he could be
the best goal scorer the premier league
has ever seen yep i agree um there's
i would say
uh since
alan share there hasn't been
nah there's been flashes but i agree no
there hasn't been a single great
goal scorer and it has it has to be
aguero yeah aguero is the closest but
just like he never out and out
goalscorer no not no i mean there's
nobody on the level of no no not even
madrid i mean there's
madrid ronaldo or barcelona messi or any
of
or bayern lewandowski or not like a guy
who's who can touch forty goals there
hasn't been and like salah got to third
even even people like
even
even iguain napoli hasn't happened you
know
i mean okay
that was one season but yeah i agree i
agree
so if we look at the last yeah four
seasons in the prem the top goal scorer
has had 23 22 23 22. five seasons ago
salah scored 32
right
but it's been under four seasons in a
row
and
we have been we've been talking a little
bit aguero and i i was deep diving a
little bit more into that and i think
that is a great place to start looking
because
right now they have been you know it's
been jesus it's been sterling and it's
been whatever up front there right
and they've been for two two and a half
seasons now just interchanging who play
up front yeah and it works it works
great
it works great but
it all it's also left people thinking oh
ct has never had a number nine well
they've had a pretty clear number nine
for about eight and a half nine seasons
so
aguero for city he's played 31 22 20 30
29 25 22
31 18 and that starts all of that starts
he's on those seasons scored
23 12 17 26 24 20 21 21 16.
so in all that time he went over the
line once yeah i agree aguero's not
earlying bertolan aguero might even be a
little bit better finisher actually like
the average of that career might just be
a little bit better but anyway i think
they had a world-class striker they get
a new world-class striker in i think
it's pretty
i i think you can draw some parallels
between those two and yeah also in terms
of games like i i think in certain games
it's just not going to make sense to
start holland even if he's uh no even if
he's fit no i agree uh
so
i think especially if he has
if if he has these little periods where
he's
not doing enough for the team like
you you know how pepe is like you play
one or two bad games and pep's just
gonna like bench you for
for nephew then adventures year four the
game brings you in at the end of the
next one starts in the champions league
after that yeah or like like he's gonna
get loads of playing time but i'm
looking at the 24 and a half goal line
and i
like everything in me screaming under i
would have put the line at 19 and a half
i think no i agree we talked about we
talked about this
a few months ago uh we were pretty
aligned coming up with this
independently we were thinking that the
line was probably going to be 22 and a
half and we were still on a pretty hard
under yeah so this is yeah this is uh
it's two goals over what we thought yeah
this is a massive under yeah it's a it's
a massive obviously we hope he's gonna
be
yeah it's a hedge
no i mean don't get me wrong i hope he's
gonna be amazing but
everything is screams under here yeah
and i think like oh so you don't think
he's gonna be a success let's say if he
scores 20 in the prem
he scores 10 in the champions league and
six in the domestic cups he's not gonna
score six in the domestic cups
he's not gonna play a bunch in the
domestic i mean if he plays a bunch of
the domestic cups just means he's uh
not yeah he's gonna play the china cares
about the semis and the finals and the
they usually put a good team up for
those
yeah they do
uh but
semis and finals
those those are not a lot good he's okay
whatever this is a hard side track but
let's say he scores 30 ish goals 22
years old first season i think that is
pretty accurate total line for him
because i don't think he's gonna play
more than the average of aguero games if
you if you tell me that he's starting 34
games in the prem i would never bet the
under
but i'm quite certain he like he's had
loads of small injuries the last years
like loads of them
uh he's quite explosive so he keeps
getting those
explosive type injuries
my guess would be he starts
20
somewhere between 22 and 27 games
another way you could look at it is
um apart from
last season jesus um
where i mean city didn't have a striker
last season so it was kind of um
uh it was kind of a kind of an outlier
um
city striker usually gets
about one expected goal per 90 minutes
yeah so you can expect holland to be
around
that number
uh and you can expect him to
finish his chances at about yeah higher
level yeah
about that clip
uh and then when you calculate the
minutes you can get the
um the uh yeah yeah the the the goals is
going to score and we would say um yeah
it's going to go
i don't think he's playing a full 90 a
lot i think no no that's
i would guess him eight
like 1900 minutes maybe yeah maybe
something like this and that's not going
to give you 25 goals no it isn't uh
there's one wild card there
like will he take the pence i don't
think so but he might take a couple
likes
i mean morris has pretty much nailed
down he plays all the time
that's that's what i'm saying he might
take a pen or two yeah not enough to
convince me no
city doesn't go to they don't get that
many pens either they should get a lot
of more but that's that's another we are
gonna be talking loads more bets and
loads more uh football and just once and
for all when we say football we mean the
type where you kick the ball uh
all the time not some of the time yeah
kick the ball all the time unless you're
the goalkeeper uh yeah that's it for
this one and we'll catch you after a
short break
the magnus effect is brought to you by
unibet by players four players
so i'm sure a lot of people have been
wondering about the world championship
recently
as many know i was in madrid for the
conclusion of
the
the candidates tournament
um
after the conclusion
i did agree to meet with um
um
with the dwarkovic and uh satovsky from
from fida to
um to talk a little bit
uh i did not
have any demands or suggestions for that
meeting
they did have
a couple of suggestions
[Music]
but
the gist of it was
that i was there to tell them that
um
i would not defend my title
in
in the next world championship match
um
and we had a small discussion they had
some suggestions uh some of them i liked
some of them i did
did not but ultimately
the
conclusion stands
one that i'm pretty comfortable with
one that i thought
a lot about
um
for a long time now i would say
more
more than a year probably
a year and a half almost since long
before the last
match
and i've spoken to
two people in
in my team i've spoken to fida
i spoke to um to yan as well
and
the conclusion is
yeah it's very simple that i am not
motivated to play
another another match i i feel
that
um
[Music]
yeah i seem i i simply
feel that
i don't have
a lot to gain i don't particularly
um i don't particularly like it
and
although
although i'm sure a match would be
would be um interesting for
historical reasons and and and all of
that i don't have
any
inclinations to play and i will
and i will simply not play the match
uh it's been
obviously
[Music]
an interesting
ride
since
[Music]
the moment i decided to to play the
candidates in
2013
uh which was to be honest on kind of a
whim
um i just at some point decided that
i'm going to give the candidates
a try
could be interesting
and
[Music]
ever since the world championship title
has obviously
has obviously given me
uh given me a lot it's it's opened
it's opened a lot of a lot of doors
and and i'm happy about that
but
the matches themselves
have
been at times interesting
at times a little bit of fun
the most fun match probably was
the one in in 2018
[Music]
at least that was the most
most interesting one and probably also
for me had the least
stressful moments because it was the
closest one and it was one that i felt
that
um obviously losing would have been
would have been very bad but it wouldn't
have been like the disaster that i
considered losing any of the
of the other
other matches
um but overall
um
i feel like it's um
it's my time to to go from the world
championship matches
i don't rule out return in
in the future but
i wouldn't wouldn't particularly
count on it
either
um just so there's no
um
ambiguity here
uh i'm not retiring from chess i'm still
going to be an active player
i'm leaving later today
to go to croatia to play the grand chess
tour
from there on i'm
gonna go to to chennai to play the
olympiad which is gonna be a lot of fun
uh norwegian team are seated as number
four there
um then to
to miami to play one of the the real
highlights of the year i feel the ftx
crypto cup
uh which is going to be awesome and
then right there um
right after that the
um
the next event after that in in the
grand chess store uh the sinkhole cup so
yeah i got a lot of chests coming up
i enjoy playing
tournaments
a lot obviously i joined them a lot more
than
i enjoyed the
um
the world championship and frankly i
don't see myself stopping as a chess
player any time
time soon
i hope to
[Music]
be able to to edge closer to one of my
other big goals which is to to make 2
900 rating
it's going to be tough obviously
but at the very least
i've
managed to
keep my rating
this year which
you know is
at least
at least something it means that
the goal is not further than it
than it was um
earlier although it's it's it it's tough
but we'll we'll see i'll just try and
do the right things uh trust the process
and um enjoy and um frankly i'm excited
to get back to
where i was
back in
2011
20
2012
start of 2013 um
where i was all set on
trying to improve trying to be better do
the right things
play the tournaments be the best in the
world
and not care about the world
championships
in terms of the world championship just
uh
do you feel like you have
achieved everything you set out to when
you when you started that journey
now and nine years ago almost
well it's more than nine years ago since
since the since the candidates um
it's hard to say i don't think i had any
other goals than to win it once then
uh
i thought
um
i'll
you know i'll uh i'll
try and keep it as long as
i'm motivated
that's fine
to be honest
2016
i was not very motivated
i feel like i mostly played that much
because other people sort of
relied on it expecting me to which is
was was fine it was not their
fault at all it was all on me for
feeling that
um
response responsibility
i did have um
instagram posts
uh
after the match in
2014 which was
two down five to go
i can reveal now that that was just
to mess with people i never had a goal
of
winning seven championships
i mean i understand the whole thing
about
legacy and all of that but
to be honest
the last match four
championships or five championships
i understand for
people who haven't been in that
situation's
situation it sounds weird and i
understand that i'm very very privileged
to to have been there when a lot of
people they spent their life trying to
do the same thing
but
four championships to five
it didn't mean anything to me
it was it was
nothing
i was satisfied with the job that i'd
done
i was happy not to have lost the match
but that was it
yeah
the magnus effect is brought to you by
unibet by players four players
and with that welcome back to the last
uh
segment of the podcast we're gonna crank
it up a little bit this is something
that we've been wanting to do for a long
time
uh
me and magnus both are
we we like waging about stuff like we we
like having these small competitions and
and
we like having some skin in the game
is that fair to say yeah that's that's
fair to say and i feel like the bets
that we have had before painful as they
may have been um
they haven't you know they haven't heard
enough so it's time to crank it up a
notch it's time
uh so uh this is gonna be the last
segment of every podcast we do it's
called the wager
uh it's called the wager for a reason
this is gonna last for a whole year like
we're gonna be competing against each
other for a whole year
every end of the podcast we're gonna do
three
different bets so it's gonna it could be
bets on next week's football games it
could be
pets on
chess even though that might be a little
bit
a little bit much of an age for magnus
but
it could be basketball it could be
anything right so
it has to be bets with two alternatives
it's win-lose or over under or whatever
and
both me and magnus we stand completely
free to take whatever side we want so we
can take the same side on all three bets
one week even though that's boring yeah
but we're going to do this for a whole
year
and we're going to calculate the points
at the end of the premier league season
next year
and this is when it gets juicy because
both me and magnus are massive meat
lovers without that
sounding too weird
uh
i i barely have a vegetarian meal in my
diet i know i should but i don't
and i know it's often the same for you
yeah i can certainly do without but
i'd rather not yeah only two days ago we
were feasting out a brazilian steakhouse
our favorite place to eat
it got messy as it always does
uh but it um
there's gonna be an end to that okay
so what we're waging for on this year's
wager
uh is
the loser has to cut out meat completely
and go
vegetarian for six months
yes and if we
so just so you understand so if we
always
bet on the same thing every week
and
we end up with the same score
then we both have to be vegetarian
okay so if it's a draw we both have to
be vegetarian uh it's
it's close to impossible that it's a
draw so i'll take that
uh
i i i could have i i could do a 10
minute long uh
party about how much i love different i
love chicken i love i love fish i really
really really love lamb and i love to
spoil myself with some kobe beef
jesus christ i don't want to lose his
bet
oh yeah i really really don't want to
lose this bet
without further ado let's do today's
three over unders let's write them down
and we'll keep going next time uh so
what we're doing this time is season
bets they're gonna be worth double to
have a little bit extra in the pot right
yeah
normal weeks the the bets are worth
the waiters are worth one
now they're worth two points
and we'll know the answer when the
premier league season is done
okay these are three random ones
you pick ipq pick first okay okay
uh arsenal over or under 64.5 points
like all of these bets are the actual
lines it's not something i made up these
are the lines from the unibed site
that's a tough one so they got a bit
better
other teams got better as well
uh
this is really really tough
um
[Music]
you know what sinchenko and jesus in i i
believe in arteta ball i'm going over
okay this is also one of the worst ones
i could like ever imagine because
i like their team i really like the way
they play sometimes but i also do
believe that arsenal's just kind of
cursed
uh
i don't particularly rate jesus or
sinchenko they're both all right but i
really like sakai like really like
urduguy
i like martinelli a lot
but the thing is
the the young team that somewhat
overachieved the last season
they sometimes progress a bit yeah i'm
gonna get i haven't checked though but
i'm gonna get that guess that united's
line is about the same
chelsea tottenham
liverpool and city are gonna be over
there is a lot of points that won't need
to go around
both
liverpool and city are probably gonna be
high 80s 90s
again okay i'm i'm
cop out i'm going over as well oh wow
i was bullish on the over but i almost
took myself into the under no but the
thing is it's very very hard to imagine
them straying too far from this line
also no i think because they have a good
team they're not going to go they're not
going to get 55 points no that's not
happening it's 6 70
62 to 70. yeah i mean 70 a lot has to go
right for
them to make 70. yeah
oh it's hard it's a it's a very good
line yeah it's very good i will i would
not recommend this bet
i could say that okay so the next one is
uh raheem sterling over or under 13 and
a half goals for chelsea
oh yeah that's right i'm first
i will say i was looking magnus dead in
the eye trying to get a read there um
i am i'm definitely going under 13 and a
half goals for sterling yep
oh that's that's a tough one
i really wonder how chelsea are gonna
look
offensively
i mean they don't have the problem is
they might play him up front yeah they
do
they don't have
that
you know what i'm going over
okay i just have a feeling i say
definitely it's not definitely but yeah
yeah
okay so the the the juice is already in
there is he a stealth top scorer
cadrette
like if you tell me he scored 18 goals i
would be sh hocked
i think he's gonna play a lot though
for chelsea he's so bad at finishing no
he's not yes no he's not
yep there's a difference between the
over and under that no he's not he's
he's an average finisher
he just he just shoots in a weird way
which makes people and he and he
misses he has awful misses and his
technique is weird that's the point
that's why people think he's he's an
average finisher no i got a question for
you about the xg
yeah when he misses the ball which he
does quite often in plain air
from about two yards he catches a little
bit of it yeah but does that count as xg
when he actually just hits the air
i don't know
when he doesn't hit the ball no but that
doesn't happen that often i don't think
that's the statistically significant can
scan someone who really knows xd find
that out first no but he was no but he i
mean
shot based ex g is not part of for sure
but like if he if he fluffs the shot
like if he just shanks it then it's then
it's a shot for sure yeah yeah but he
very often like if he misses it misses
his shooting foot and hits his standing
foot that happens yeah i don't think
that's a shot okay yep interesting um
i would still say he's an average
finisher i i'm i mean i believe in
okay i'm all aboard the sterling train
i'm gonna get it i'm gonna get him in my
fantasy uh so how is your fantasy team
looking right now [ __ ] off
by the way none of us have made teams no
we guys it's too early yeah it's too
early it's too early you need to have
the self-respect to at least pretend
that you have a life in july
and don't start your fantasy team as
soon as it comes out oh i i i very much
very much agree
okay last one uh last one of the pod is
everton over or under 44 and a half
points
yeah you see i didn't just go with the
big hitters no this these are give the
toffees a little shout
these are interesting
very interesting lines uh so under means
that
they're probably gonna be
in the relegation battle or one of those
just above it or one of those what for
teams that get to 40 points and then
just coast
which to be fair i think everton did a
few seasons ago like they got to like 43
and then they didn't get any more
points
um
so what what do they have they got
they lost richarlison who was their best
i also want to say to people right now
just so they know that we
we're doing a
dark version of this so there's no
internet no googling
dude all he does now all you do now you
have to do off the top of your yeah
you're not allowed to research this [ __ ]
obviously um
obviously you've researched the [ __ ]
before you gave me the bet so that's a
little bit unfair i i i will promise
that i haven't and
i will also uh i will also say that uh
okay i followed the premier last year so
we follow it quite quite closely
but uh we will also get um
we will also get a third guy to choose
out the bets for us going forward sure
yeah that's nice to make it
even
more fair yeah um anyway so they lost
richardson who was the best player
they got tarkovsky winks
and winks
i'm not sure i love the team
now i'm going under
yeah boring as [ __ ] i'm definitely going
under as well
injury-prone
calvert-lewin um i have very little
faith in frank lampard as a manager i
think they need to go down to make
something off this team i like anthony
gordon
but that's about it
i'm fine with anthony gordon
okay so the big difference right now is
the sterling bet okay we'll keep doing
that we'll we will keep coming with
these uh
podcasts this is it for the magnus
effect thank you for listening thank you
the magnus effect is brought to you by
unibed by players four players